all right good afternoon everyone I have
the best slot just after
just so you know if you if you're not
off and fall asleep I'd be totally
alright with that so so my name is La
Vie and I look after machine learning
technology at a company called mani HL
and what what a child does is we build
predictive model models for financial
markets so we use all sorts of different
kinds of data sets to figure out what's
going to happen to the world's financial
markets or tomorrow and text data is one
of them so I'm going to talk to you
about about that today and part of my
role is is looking after machine
learning technology is implementing the
predictive models trading and production
but also a big part of it is making our
researchers more productive and so this
is is kind of part of making our
researchers more productive so before I
get going I mean this is going to be
kind of the plan for today
I'm gonna talk a bit about the framework
that or the frame of what of what we're
trying to achieve talk very briefly
about NLP in general then I'm going to
talk to you about a baby open source
project which for its increased dramatis
am I'm going to try to open source today
as part of this talk and and I'm also
going to try to do a live demo as well
so what can possibly go wrong and then
if you think that that that tool might
be helpful to what you do I'm going to
talk about how to integrate it within
your research process but with before we
get going how many of you do natural
language processing whoa
okay good so for visualization can you
just maybe shout some of the packages
that you use for for visualizing text
data and maybe the name of the package
and what it does in up to three words
perfect so space in this place in
particular for for visualizing the the
trees okay okay good what does it do
perfect great anything else
great rat okay Brad I always do this job
ILD this what does it do
good visualizing the output of Lda the
word embeddings projector from yeah
exactly good anything else perfect okay
maybe one more fine ROM of course but
all right um good so even if I do a
really crappy job as a speaker these
really helpful people have already kind
of done my job and taught you something
useful so hopefully you'll be using
these libraries in in what you do okay
so for those of you who don't do natural
language processing this is I'm going to
try to frame the problem so that you can
maybe understand why this library that
we're gonna be open sourcing is helpful
so this is a typical data set so in a
typical text data set you would
obviously have lots and lots of textual
documents and so this is an example of
an article coming from The Wall Street
Journal and so in our case in finance we
might be interested in anything from
really really short documents like
tweets to really long documents like
company any reports that might be
hundreds of pages long alright so the
obvious thing is if you're doing text
data then your textual data set is going
to have lots and lots of documents okay
but the other thing is that your date
set is going to have lots of metadata
that's associated with these documents
so everything from boring things like
the title the date it it the let's say
the news article was published the date
you actually saw it where it was written
who wrote it which companies are
mentioned which to which topic
it it refers to and things like that and
so actually if you look at the typical
data set it'd be this combination of the
documents themselves plus the metadata
for the documents and textual data sets
tend to be quite big and by that I mean
at least in our world it can be both
really wide so have lots and lots of
metadata that either
you yourself extracted or came from the
data vendor we tend to buy data from
data vendors so it might come with lots
and lots of columns
it might also have lots and lots of rows
so hundreds of thousands to millions to
to many millions documents and even on
disk it can be quite big so planned
eight sites might be many terabytes and
then as an NLP researcher then you make
your metadata even wider by annotating
these documents with many more kind of
quantifications of the document so
measures of sentiment
novelty relevance whatever it it might
be and then the final thing to mention
is that when you do NLP your models
pretty much always tend to be pipelines
of different discrete steps and even
even if you're trying to do the most
basic thing like classifying documents
into multiple classes you might start
with your raw data which may be like
PDFs or XML sorta jacent or whatever it
might be maybe you've scraped it off the
of the web and it's a in HTML then you
have to extract the text then you have
to take the text and maybe break it down
into paragraphs and words and then maybe
you're going to do stemming or lay
memorization to do things like was work
is was all become beep so that your rest
of your pipeline is more robust and then
of course because it's really expensive
to store text data then you're going to
vectorize it by attracting the
dictionary and then converting the words
into just indices in that dictionary and
this is just pre-processing we haven't
even started to do anything interesting
as of yet so this kind of pipeline
nature of things just in current to NLP
and those of you who raised their hints
hopefully agree
then if you're a good researcher like
all of you here
of course you care about actually
knowing the data that you're trying to
model so you don't just take your data
set put a black box next to it great
results come out and then you're happy
and you go home but actually what you
try to do is understand the data you're
working with and and also very
importantly you understand what the
model that you just trained us and so
the tasks that you end up doing range
from exploratory tasks like reviewing
the metadata to identify documents that
are of interest then reviewing samples
of from the corpus so looking at
different documents where they're
randomly chosen or chosen as a result of
you looking at the metadata then you go
through maybe debugging so trying to
figure out why your model is not
producing what do you think should be
producing all the way to - to
introspection so really getting a sense
of what are the things that the models
getting right and wrong so that you can
improve it and for all of that ideally
you'd give tooling to help you do your
job so I just try to do a very very non
exhaustive list of some of the packages
that that people have mentioned here I
seriously encourage you to look at this
last link which case I don't know
hundreds of different visualizations of
data that may be useful to you but the
core messages there are lots of packages
out there that help us visualize the
output of specific models so this is
really good now the thing is what I need
as an NLP researcher is actually one
level above I don't see too many things
so I'd not yet seen good tools that
allow me to do this exploring my broad
corpus like my entire corpus navigating
through the documents and then zooming
from there down into actually
understanding what my model is doing so
so we thought that might be a useful
thing to create and so ideally what I'd
like to do is have a tool that
that here's an interactive UI to
visualize my documents my metadata and
my pipelines where it's all connected
researchers I'm sure you all agree
they're all different and have different
things that they care about
so creating trying to put too much
structure into anyone - is going to fail
miserably so you want to create
something that's very flexible
extensible where people can bring in
their own visualizations it has to be
super super simple minimalistic and easy
to plug in because if I have to teach
you for two days how to plug in my
visualization - you're gonna leave five
minutes into it and then obviously given
that the date sets that we work with are
really big the the tool has to scale to
big datasets and any case to be
extensible so I should be able to add my
own dataset visualizations and things
like that and being PI data it of course
must be written in Python I have a star
there because Python doesn't really do
UI is very well and so it unavoidable
yes I actually agree with that yes but
you have to write potentially some some
JavaScript as part of as part of the
thing that you're building not use a
researcher but if you're trying to
create a visualizer it's unavoidable to
go into the world of JavaScript
hopefully that would however be
completely hidden from the researchers
who for sure don't want to be writing
JavaScript okay so we thought right that
sounds like an amazing open amazing
opportunity for an intern project and it
was intern season it @hl and I was
thinking about kind of what are some of
the cool projects that we can give to
the upcoming cohort of interns and I
thought okay this is going to be a
really useful for us be a cool project
to work on because it's quite creative
and and and and third if the intern does
a good job then it h oh we love open
sourcing things and we are heavy users
of open source and so if it goes well
then maybe we will even give it away to
the world and so now
I'm going to shamelessly talk about the
were the work of one of my interns Alex
who ended up creating a tool that that
the interns ended up naming Panorama
you'll see why in a second and so now
I'm going to go into the part that can
only go wrong okay so what I'm going to
try to do now is show you what panorama
does alright so so first of all this is
a dataset of Reuters news that is
available as part of any otk of course
you probably have all seen it what I
have here is just a visualization of my
entire corpus that allows me to see all
the news maybe I can zoom in so that
well right that allows me to see all the
news I can see that there are about
10,000 of them in the corpus I can kind
of jump through the different pages I
can sort by the different columns and I
can do things like for example can I
find all the news that that are talking
about whatever banks so I can do search
in the headline find everything that
talks about Bank there we go so very
simple operations that allow me to kind
of just understand the the metadata a
little bit better and because like I
said text date this date set can be
quite big here we've just shown a few of
the columns but then I can easily show
more or remove some of the columns that
on that I don't care about so if I have
a really kind of wide dataset then I can
choose what I'm looking at okay so so
far all we've done is effectively
allowed us to explore the metadata a
little bit more efficiently okay but of
course so far I've not really shown you
the documents themselves so the next
thing we have so actually let me go back
to showing you the headline alright so
next the next thing we have is this
notion of the computation pipeline and
so here I have the world's simplest NLP
pipelined
no matter what you do you'll never have
something quite as simplistic but for
the purposes of a demo I thought it was
okay so here I'm just going to have two
stages the raw document as it comes from
the Reuters news dataset and then a
powered version of the document where
the text is broken down into paragraphs
and the paragraphs are broken down into
into words and so I can see my pipeline
let me make this a bit smaller right and
then what I can do is I can pick one of
my documents and I can click on a note
in the pipeline and and visualize that
document and then depending on the
semantics of the note so if it's just a
raw text note that I'm just gonna see
that the contents of the of the document
but then if it's for example this parsed
parse document then I can see quickly
the the sentences and then I can zoom
into each individual sentence and then I
could even show these things side by
side and then I can maybe kind of move
them around and stuff like that open
them close them and so on so that part
allows me to to really drill from the
entire data set that we see on the Left
through a given node in the pipeline to
to the individual potentially words and
sentences and when I say that each note
can be anything you want so imagine a
note can be a word embedding visualizer
it could be a topic model visualizer in
anything really so in our case we have a
bunch of visualizes that we've created
already but obviously we expect to
create to create many more and and I
thought finally I was going to show you
just another very simple task that you
might be interested in which is just
let's say you've trained a classifier
and you're trying to figure out where
your classifier is going wrong so here
I've annotated 60 documents because I
was lazy just for the purposes of this
demo and and so I have a column called
truth and
I've trained simple naive based model to
tell me whether the documents are
positive or negative so now what I'd
like to do is look at different cells of
my confusion matrix and so in in at the
moment it's as simple as just doing
first of all I'm going to drop all the
older nuns so to get to get all the
documents that the human case has
classified then I'm going to search for
all the documents where the human
thought that they were positive and then
I can search then for all the documents
where my naive based model thought that
they were for example neutral and then I
can kind of bring in my pipeline back to
life I can then open them all and very
quickly flip through them as opposed to
what people normally do in the console
have their pandas transformations find
the document look at it find another one
and things like that all right that was
probably too much of a whirlwind tour
but this is generally what panorama does
it creates a little bit of a framework
for different visualizations to be to be
put together with the data so that you
can explore the corpus you can visualize
your pipeline and you can visualize the
models themselves and why they're making
the decisions that they're making okay
so with that presumably to some of you
that may be useful so I'm if it's not
I'm sure you you can either nod off or
or go get some coffee or something like
that but what I'm going to do now is
just show you how you can plug in your
own data into panorama and try to
convince you that it's hopefully that
it's quite easy so before we get going
with that I thought I'd give you the few
core concepts you have to you have to
know with what we're calling into
panorama such that you know the rest of
the API is make sense
we were very creative so we've called
the table in the middle of the table
we've called these things on the side
searching sorting filtering and so on
we've called them transforms and
transforms take the data and then
transform it by let's say filtering it
and then return another another table so
transform steak table and a
transformation and then return a
transform table we call the thing on
there under I'd the pipeline and then we
call the things viewers okay so with
that if you wanted to plug in your own
date sets into panorama all you need to
do is implement three functions one
function that supports the table so you
can think of it as something that
returns a data frame wrapped into an
object that can transform itself one
function that returns the pipeline and
one function that given a given primary
key within the table and a node of the
pipeline returns the content that the
viewer needs so that said that they can
suggest we can show you the topic model
or the word embedding or or the
sentiment results or something like that
so now we're going to go through all
three in in in sequence so first of all
gate table is just a function that
returns a table object a table table
object knows like I said how to
transform itself and here's a link and
that will we really need to to know
about it we've implemented multiple
different and you can think of it as
you're kind of the backend that serves
the data we've implemented multiple
backends one is really convenient for
researchers and just wraps up angles
data frame so if you can load your
metadata as a data frame in one line
you're you're you're good but the other
one is wrapping [ __ ] collections
because the ratio we store a lot of our
data into [ __ ] and so it then delegates
all of these operations like searching
and solar sorting and filtering directly
to MongoDB such that we can scale to big
datasets if your metadata was in
something like sequel then you can write
yourself
a a sequel query back-end it's quite
it's quite simple you know probably
write one anyway and then we already
provides a bunch of transformations with
both of the backends things like
sampling sorting searching range queries
to only look at the top 5% of the of the
distribution for example computing
histograms and things like that and just
to convince you that if you have your
data in pandas it's quite easy to plug
it in this is all you need to write oh
by the way for this demo and this I'm
pretty much going to show you all the
code that I had to write so that I can
plug in the Reuters news data so if you
can load the data into a data frame this
is how you get your table then the
pipeline is actually even simpler than
that it's literally you have to define
the graph and the way we've chosen to
define the graph is by just specifying a
dict
where the key is the name of the node in
the graph and the value lists the
parents of that node in the pipeline and
then also give you an idea for what
viewer should be used so for example it
says I'm a topic model node or I'm a man
XML note I'm a PDF node such that the UI
can then connect you to the right viewer
when you kind of click on a given a
given node and so here
that was the pipeline that I used I have
two nodes the raw node that is just of
the raw type so it uses the raw viewer
and then a document tree node which just
shows you this arbitrarily deep tree
where it's parent is the raw node and
the viewer that I want to be using is
this document reviewer okay and then the
third API you have to implement is and
by the way I should say you don't really
have to implement anything but the gate
table because sometimes when I start
looking at a new data set I just want to
play around with the metadata to see
what's in it and so you can literally
write that one line of Python and then
start just playing around with the data
filtering it messing about with it then
I tend to implement
a get pipeline that just shows me the
roll the document in its raw state such
that as I play around with my data set I
can also visualize the documents
themselves so typically my get-back
pipeline at the very beginning has one
note and that note is whatever the raw
format of the data is XML PDF and so on
and then I start adding more notes as my
model gets more complicated and then
finally the get record function just
takes the primary key of the note in the
data frame and the name of the stage
that was clicked in the graph and then
prepares something for the viewer so if
the viewer is a PDF viewer then you're
going to return to the path to the PDF
if it's an XML viewer then you're going
to return the XML string and if it's a
word embedding viewer might it might
return a vector for example of
floating-point numbers same for the
topic model and then we have a bunch of
these implemented we also have a few
viewers that we haven't yet open sourced
so that will happen as well and in this
case for that demo here's what my get
record looks like NLT case corpus has a
function called raw which given a key
just gives you the text of the document
and so if the stage that I clicked was
raw then I just returned that as a
string and if the stage that I clicked
was the documentary then I just sent
them sent tokenize and we're tokenize
lazily and i guess that's another
important aspect to it hmm as a kind of
a case that's how we use it internally
when we as we develop the models we
eventually we use spark to process our
entire corpus and get all the let's say
get matrix for every document but
initially what you'd like to do is if
you've written a new function just run
it on a few documents and so what we end
up having is a library which has
functions that take us from one node in
the graph to the next and then we would
implement the pipeline with click around
the documents and click around the nodes
and see for certain documents what kind
of what what the model does and when
we're hippy then run these functions
using spark on the entire corpus so that
allows us to kind of play around with
the data it's small-scale and then and
then run the model on the entire data
set that doesn't always work for all
kinds of models of course but for
certain things it actually works quite
well this sort of lazy evaluation of the
nodes of course if you've computed every
document in every stage already
then this can just be a lookup in your
park a files or whatever they might be
that's what we use okay and then this is
a sort of web server running to support
your your UI so pretty much if you look
at this code the only line that you care
about is is this where you just register
the datasets that you use so the three
functions that I showed you you just
wrap them in in a class that descends
from this view that's part of the
framework and then we have a helper
function called make server which makes
a flask flask up and then just register
or that all the date sets that you're
interested in and then we have an index
page that allows you to jump between
data sets and then within each data set
that you already show what I already
showed you what you can do all right
and then for extra credit I guess there
there are a few more functions that are
part of fine Rama so in your views you
want you might want to implement them as
well one is called load which is just
you just get called one off by the
framework to to create that data frame
that we're wrapping into a table and
then the other one is called get config
which allows you to send all sorts of
different conflicts to the UI so
followed it literally is a function that
goes and maybe load your data from disk
or from a database or whatever the
metadata and and read it let's say as a
data frame it doesn't catch anything so
if you kill your server and start it
again if your load operation is slow
then you're going to have to wait so
internally what we end up doing is
have a caching layer that just puts the
materialized metadata into [ __ ] but
which would probably we'll open source
as well but if your date sets are not
too big and loading them is quick then
you don't need to do anything special
and so this was my load for the Reuters
dataset it just goes and loads the path
the category is the headline and the
length from from the Reuters data this
was my class I had trained an if base
and a support vector machine classifier
and so this just reads the truth and
enbe column that I was showing you joins
the two and then I have my data frame
and then finally get config gives the UI
information about what's the primary key
of the documents in your data set what
transformations are allowed on that
particular data set the name of the
column can be the list of columns that
are initially visible and then we have a
helper function called make config which
hides a way what the internal format of
the config is said that you can just
create it like that and it gets sent to
the to the UI that's it really panoramas
written in flask on the backend side and
on the front front and side to choose is
reacting with ducks and one thing I
should say is that there's actually even
more JavaScript code and there's Python
code except that as a research we don't
have to worry about it
and then you can create your own
anything you can create your own
transformers you can create your own
viewers you can create your own backends
in case your data is not in in [ __ ] or
CSV and then of course most importantly
you can plug in your own dataset and oh
this is a false statement at the moment
panorama is not yet open source so for
increased dramatise enlike I was telling
you I thought that what we were gonna do
now so this is the repo as you can see
it is a thing it is on github so it must
be official oh it's not on Facebook
spore but but then it has some
documentation and he has some demos
and so what I'm gonna do now is I'm
gonna do this go to settings I'm gonna
do make public huh I hear oh no I have
to type in my password there we go
binary Rama's now open source all right
actually all of these go to Alex all
right so so pine room is now open stores
I didn't have a slide if that if that
didn't work by the way so I don't know
what I would have done but okay
thankfully plan around was now open
source so as we know it PI data now a
little open source baby is born so
unless we give it love she's gonna die
so not saying you you should contribute
but you kind of probably have to
otherwise so so as any nascent open
source project it needs a lot of love so
we'll keep kind of nurturing it but of
course if this is in any way useful we
would appreciate if fathers got involved
so we spend a lot of Alex this time kind
of iterating on the ideas so that we can
have something simple and clean and
extensible and so on so there's more
tests to be written then also we want to
create more advanced viewers so like I
mentioned connecting creating a viewer
for maybe display C or for pi L devs and
and for word embeddings and things like
that creating more advanced transformers
so a great starter project is just a
transformer for a confusion matrix such
that you can just choose the two columns
and then it and then we can render the
confusion matrix for you and then if you
click on a node then it automatically
filters the table like I already
mentioned caching but the other another
thing is we use this in production
actually to live monitor datasets we we
built it and then we discovered it's
just the data frame viewer which for
each node allows you to have a pipeline
it doesn't really have much to do with
NLP if you go one level
more abstract so you could be doing
computer vision research and that still
applies because you have your pipelines
or in our case we have all sort of kind
of pipelines of things happening so so
if you have reports monitoring your
system in production then you probably
want them to be refreshing themselves on
some sort of cadence so creating a
scheduler for that might be another
useful task and so on I guess the key
message is contributions are welcome
so panorama has you so now is is open
source so I've already filed a bunch of
issues that we'll be working through but
if you're interested in getting involved
well a come speak to me I'd love to tell
you more or just get engaged online I
have three minutes 50 seconds left until
the end of my talk that's really good
I'm never in that position good well
that's all I had for you so if you have
any questions give it to take them
any questions so all you need to do to
you install it and then we implement
your class that wraps your data set and
then you have these three lines at the
bottom that start the server and so you
just start the command line from the
command line you just start the server
for you so you don't have to host it
anywhere
as a researcher you just run it locally
and then it has this UI so for example
this place it works the same way so in
Spacey if you do the space and then you
try to visualize a parse tree then it
ends up creating a server for you so
it's exactly the same kind of idea I've
got a questionnaire there as you say do
you have an image viewer go in to these
images because I'm saying in JavaScript
that's like you know well we don't have
an image viewer component to show images
but that's gonna be a great first
contribution for somebody yeah yeah I
got you lined the code yes where is it a
question yes I'm here
I don't even a word the scene maybe
maybe everybody was wondering about
image viewers just quick you said you
had an intern working on that could you
give an estimate of roughly how long
they spent on it because it's really
impressive but yeah he's a he's a very
good guy well the D so it was a summer
project so we went from kind of scratch
initially iterate it many many times on
what this should look like and what the
scope should be because it's very easy
well I hope you don't think we created
something over engineered but but let's
assume you don't think so creating
something that's fairly simple Indian
takes a lot of effort to kind of we
deleted a lot of code for example for
everything that but yeah a summer
project plus we gave it some love
afterwards okay well if we don't have
any more questions I assume it's because
everybody's contributing right now
so you can just catch him after the talk
and thank you
[Applause]